hello hi guys uh this is the making of
for minecraft the last minecart i'm
sorry you guys had to wait so long for
it we were very busy but you'll enjoy it
trust me so when we were conceptualizing
the minecraft short uh we were trying to
take like the elements of survival and
zombies and fighting your way with
monsters and kind of combine that with
like those gritty inner city zombie
movies minecraft zombie apocalypse
essentially for the costumes we actually
made them for halloween for a party
where everybody thought we were either
robots or lego dudes it was the nerd
poker halloween party i was actually a
little bit disappointed we totally out
nerded everybody at the party sam and
jimmy were minecraft dudes i made the
zombie one we kept the costumes because
we thought we'd make a video out of them
hey what do you know so we shot
minecraft in like the gritty alleys of
los angeles downtown area um there was a
graffiti pang of master chief in one of
the alleyways that we thought was pretty
appropriate so we had the pleasure of
meeting notch in person at a machinima
live stream we got to have him sign our
little diamond pickaxe that we made and
it's really awesome we got to be on the
show and meet him and talk and he's a
really cool guy he's basically a big
jolly swedish santa claus i can see why
he made minecraft so the movie opens
overlooking the los angeles landscape
but of course los angeles doesn't look
like it's actually made in minecraft so
he actually went to minecraft took all
our sweet creations and made a big map
painting out of it yeah actually as you
can see here we have a big statue nico
made we have a big bridge that brandon
made and some other great landscape
stuff was fun so we took screenshots of
those chopped them together and kind of
made a landscape out of that and dropped
that in the shot using some motion
tracking a little bit of color grading
some smoke things like that and we had a
good matte painting so the workbench
shots were pretty simple basically i
took the actual icons to use in the game
and i motion track the shot using boojoo
and drop them in as little 2d floating
layers in after effects there's a very
simple effect but it's very effective at
getting that good workbench feel so the
crater wasn't actually that hard of an
effect but it was one of people's
favorites so the first step in a show
like this is to do a 3d motion track
once again we use the program like fuji
a lot of you guys have been asking for a
tutorial we'll make one soon for the
creator all i did was model a big blocky
crater that had a good flat outline
around it and this allowed me to put the
texture of the minecraft blocks on the
inside and then for everything
surrounding it on the border i used a
matte shadow material the matte shadow
material around the crater makes it so
that even though the crater is going
underneath the ground it blocks off all
view of it unless viewed from the proper
perspective so for the zombies there's
two types of effects we did one of which
is basically just painting out faces or
arms and things like that and the other
is the full 3d zombies for the effect of
the pickaxes and all the pixelated blood
we actually had jimmy in costume there
and when we knocked off like the head in
the arm we actually just painted off the
head by replacing with some of the
background after we were done taking the
shot we'd have jimmy leave the frame get
a blank frame of just the background and
put that back in there so if we cut
anything out you just show through to
the background and we motion track the
shot so it's really easy just add a
piece of the background back into the
shot so for jimmy i covered up his arm
using a little blue splotch and i
painted out his head using the method
described earlier and when i was all
done i put pixelated blood in front of
all of it to cover up my mistakes
to pixelate the blood we just used the
mosaic filter in after effects to build
the 3d models i took pictures of the
various pieces of the costume and then
just textured that onto the 3d models it
was really easy because the guys are
just blocks i use the arch and design
material in 3ds max to texture these
costumes because it gives me a lot of
good controls over the surface
properties it makes it look really
realistic so then for when the guys get
blown up we actually use rayfire for the
physics simulation usually we use
rayfire to fragment or destroy things
but it also lets you just select objects
and have them bounce around so it's
perfect add some pixelated blood on top
of that too boom done so we actually
kind of like the effect that zombie's
getting shot so he decided to just make
a whole bunch of getting shot and made
it a bonus video yeah we felt like there
really wasn't enough of it in the actual
video so hey why not make more
so the minecraft video is the most
popular video on our channel and
actually did a huge part in helping us
grow as filmmakers on youtube so thanks
everybody for watching it a lot of
people like the music too if you guys
want to take a listen to paid in blood
by gravedigger we got a lot of
inspiration from that thanks for
watching our videos guys i hope you
learned something if you have any
questions about anything hit us up at
twitter or you can go to facebook
see you later have a good time bye
[Music]